this video is brought to you by
Squarespace from websites and online
stores to marketing tools and analytics
Squarespace is the all-in-one platform
to build a beautiful online presence and
run your business
check out Squarespace through the link
in the description below more on lamina
bits he was the undisputed king of rock
and roll in the mid 1950s 20 year-old
Elvis Presley exploded onto the airwaves
with a rockabilly blends of country
music and blues is curled lip and
trademark wiggling hips for southern boy
caused a sensation coming just as youth
culture was taking off Elvis was
everything these new teenagers wanted he
was dangerous rebellious and anathema to
their parents across the nation
preachers denounced him from their
pulpits judges issued writs against him
for corrupting morals the National Guard
was even called to one of his concerts
if you were alive in 1956 then you
likely thought Elvis was either the
sexiest or most dangerous man alive yet
who feels that way today mention Elvis's
name now and you're most likely to
conjure images of a fat sweaty dude
warbling away in Las Vegas his
preposterous white suit still stained
with the grease of 10,000 hamburgers so
how did the king of rock and roll
transform into its blubbery punchline
well today by graphics were gonna get in
our DeLorean and go all the way back to
the 1950s to witness the birth of a new
generation and the life of that
generations greatest icon
although he grew up to become the king
there was nothing noble about the story
of Elvis's birth on January the 8th 1935
Elvis Aaron Presley was born into a
world that was groaning under the weight
of the Great Depression his father
Vernon President it was an odd job man
while his mother Gladys was barely
scraping by the two lived in East Tupelo
a small town known back then as one of
the roughest places in Mississippi
although the family did have their own
house to rim shotgun Shack practically
small enough to fit inside your average
briefcase it was without electricity
indoor plumbing or much of anything else
in fact the present EES were so poor
that they had to rely on welfare to pay
the doctor who delivered Elvis or rather
delivered Elvis and his twin yes twin
Elvis was originally meant to be brother
to Jesse Garon Presley but the younger
twin emerged stubborn and he almost
wasn't the only one the birth nearly
kills both Gladys and Elvis and the two
were rushed to hospital although both
pulled through the shock of losing Jesse
seems to have permanently scarred Gladys
for the rest of her life she would be
ferociously overprotective of Elvis but
that was all for the future for the
first part of his life baby Elvis
experienced nothing but non-stop
deprivation Gladys and Vernon were so
poor that they had to rely on their
neighbors to buy diapers shockingly this
was their financial high points in 1938
Vernon was jailed for forging a four
dollar check and their Shack was
repossessed as Gladys moved about
staying with friends
three-year-old Elvis took to sitting out
on the front steps bawling his eyes out
for his dead to come home yet even after
Vernon's early 1939 release for good
behavior
things still did not improve for the
family they spent years bouncing between
different rental places moving in and
out of public assistance housing there's
a great little legend attached to this
age for Elvis is supposed to have
overheard his parents arguing about
money and told them not to worry because
one day he was gonna buy them a Cadillac
needless to say this childish boast
would turn out to be more accurate than
Vernon or Gladys could have ever
predicted and so life passed
Vernon continued doing odd jobs and the
family continued wallowing in poverty
and Elvis finally started school but
even now there were signs of the legend
that he would become in 1945 one of
teachers overheard him singing she was
so impressed by his voice that she took
him to the principal who was so
impressed that he insisted that Elvis
enter a talent show that was held on
October the 3rd 10 year old Elvis came
to stand up at the Mississippi Alabama
Fair and dairy show and sing old shap
the event was broadcast on Welo radio
the first time the world or Mississippi
at any rate heard Elvis Presley's voice
well we'd love to tell you that some
stock character in the studio
immediately cried go tzuke's this kid's
got something the reality it was
actually nothing so narrative ly
pleasing instead Elvis placed a poultry
fifth in the talent show and well that
was that except of course it wasn't on
Elvis's 11th birthday Gladys took him to
buy a present Elvis was determined to
either get a rifle or a bike but both
gifts were so dangerous that just
thinking about them gave the
overprotective Gladys palpitations so
she convinced her son's make do with a
cheaper gift instead one which would
keep him out of trouble
and that's how in January 1946 Elvis
Presley got his first guitar
[Music]
the next big shift in young Elvis's life
came in November 1948 that month Vernon
and Gladys moved all the way north to
Memphis hoping for a fresh start for
their music loving son it was like
spending your entire life listening to
only one tune only to suddenly discover
Spotify exists and well dear God there's
music everywhere although the family
were still in public housing it was now
in a city thrumming with blues with
country with gospel with anything that
might make you dance at school to the
new city meant a new Alvis suddenly the
boy was wearing his how long well long
for the 50s and slicked back and pairing
it with colorful stylish outfits out
whence Elvis the mama's boy and
teacher's pet and in came Elvis the Rock
and Roll rebel at least that was the
image in reality Elvis pretty much
stayed out of trouble despite what his
swagger might have suggested okay so now
let's jump forward a few years past the
end of the 40's past the Korean War and
right on to the summer of 1953 where
Elvis had just graduated and got a job
driving trucks at this point America is
on the cusp of becoming what you imagine
when you think of 1950s USA the portable
transistor radio was months away from
debuting little Richard had just signed
with peacock Records and rock and roll
was slowly becoming a bit of a thing
teens they were starting to become
consumers leading to the first ripples
of youth culture in short it was a world
transforming with a new teen let culture
just waiting for its leader it would
find him in Memphis that summer 1953
Elvis got a four dollar advance from his
job and went to the Memphis recording
service to cut a single in later years
the King would simply say that he wanted
to hear what he sounded like
but since the service was owned by Sun
Records as Sam Phillips it seemed more
likely that Elvis wanted to get noticed
not that that immediately happened after
famously telling the assistant at the
servers I don't sound like nobody Elvis
cut his record and paid his four bucks
and well there was nothing for all year
of his waiter driving trucks and hoping
for the best at some points in those 12
months he must have started to wonder if
his muse
career was ever gonna go anywhere then
on June the 26th 1954 he finally got the
call marion keisker Sun Records wanted
to know if he could be at the studio by
3:00 as Elvis later said I was there by
the time she hung up the phone the
session Elvis sang in that day wasn't
great but it was good enough for Sam
Phillips to call him back on July the
fifth that day nothing much seems to be
happening in the booth no magic no
nothing bummed out everyone took a break
and that's when it happened to unwind
Elvis casually started playing a version
of Arthur crude ups blues song that's
all right only we're the faster tempo
and a laid-back style as he played
session guitarist Scotty Moore and
bassist Bill Black joined in suddenly
the song was transformed into something
more than blues it was a whole new sound
the trio cut their single that very same
day none of them could have known it as
they left the studio and stepped out
into their warm Memphis evening but
there just found their golden ticket
when that's all right hit the airwaves
it was gonna transform their lives when
Fame came for Elvis it didn't slowly
caught him it grabs him like some kind
of out-of-control Fame Hawk dragging him
right up into the stratosphere on July
the 8th local station whbq was handed
Elvis's record by Sam Phillips and asked
to play it when they did the switchboard
lit up like a Christmas tree so many
people called him that whbq played
that's all right again and again and
again by the time the show ended Elvis's
record had been heard all over the state
and people were going nuts from that
point on Elvis's destiny was fixed he
was gonna be the biggest damn star that
Memphis had ever seen the summer was a
wild one for the boy and his musicians
from driving trucks Elvis was suddenly
being driven all over Tennessee all over
the deep south playing endless gigs
because they only had that one record
that's all they played Johnny Cash later
recalled seeing Elvis at one gig just
sing that's all right over ends over
like a record stuck on repeat yet people
loved it try and imagine for a moment
what it must have felt like to be Elvis
Presley that summer how it must have
felt driving from town to town
the windows rolled down and a cool
breeze blowing through a slicked back
hair
knowing that your time had come it must
have been magical the sort of feeling
you can't ever recapture on October the
16th Elvis played the Louisiana Hayride
radio show his voice transmitting to 13
states the response was so good that
producers had him sign a year-long
contract then and there it meant enough
money for him to quit his day job but
hayride is important in the Elvis story
for another reason
a month after Elvis began his contract a
shady music promoter began working with
hayride a guy who claimed he was from
West Virginia but couldn't quite hide
his Dutch accent yes it is time to
introduce Colonel Tom Parker a major
impresario in the south Parker is a guy
with a background so strange it's
tempting to think that he's just stepped
out of a Hollywood mwah he claimed to be
American but was really from the
Netherlands his title of colonel was
only honorary and the one time had
really been in the army it actually
deserted his past was full of weird
tales like running carnival road shows
or intentionally eating until he was too
fat to fight in World War two he likely
was ins and naturalized US citizen and
it's even thought today that he might
have fled the Netherlands after killing
someone but Parker did have one vital
skill he knew Talent when he saw it and
he knew how to make that talent a
household name Elvis finally met Parker
On January the 15th 1955 immediately
Parker began to muscle into the young
man's career pushing Elvis's other
manager out of the picture at times this
was done via ballsy moves like stomping
up ten thousand dollars of his own money
to buy of us out of his Sun Records
contract so that he could move into the
bigger label RCA at others it was done
via almost sociopathic behavior within
days of James Dean's death in a car
wreck that September Parker was on the
phone to Warner Brothers insisting that
they just stick Elvis in any unfinished
James Dean film but if Elvis disapproved
of these methods or of the man himself
he didn't show it on November the 21st
1955 Elvis signs the RCA contract Parker
had negotiated it netted him $5,000 plus
a guarantee that it play on television
within 60 days On January the 28th for
1956 Elvis sang for the
time to a national audience on CBS's
stage show at the time Elvis was a mere
20 years old
by the time you turn 21 he'd be the
biggest star on the planet and maybe
you're gonna be a star and you might
need a place to row your music or maybe
you just do something else that needs a
presence online and well now it's time
for me to introduce you to today's
sponsor Squarespace a couple of simple
things one maybe you've got some idea
for a website or a business floating
around in your brain and well - the only
way to figure out whether that's worth
doing is to get it out to the world and
of course that can be daunting because
it's scary to go and try new things to
pursue new ideas but not knowing how to
set up a website is not an excuse there
are no excuses available with
Squarespace Squarespace allows you to
create a powerful website for whatever
you're up to want to sell something
online yes it's easy to set up a store
with Squarespace of or a podcast
absolutely starting a YouTube channel
where you do that on YouTube you want a
website to complement it it all starts
on Squarespace with a beautiful template
that you can customize to your heart's
content or you can start from scratch or
just move over from an existing domain
making everything super easy to manage
but don't start from scratch
use a template like I say don't make
excuses and once you've gone through the
super easy customization process there
are no updates there are no patches
there's no teknon cents to deal with
they've also got 24/7 customer support
he will help you out whenever you've got
a question so at the Squarespace calm
for a free trial and when you're ready
to launch go to Squarespace calm /by
graphics and you'll save 10% off your
first purchase of a website or a domain
let's get back to the video
[Music]
when Elvis arrived on national stage it
was amid a whirlwind of controversy
we don't just mean as a white guy
playing black music although that
annoyed plenty we mean something almost
more concerning to 1950s prudes Elvis
was sexy
you know those images of Beatlemania
with teenage girls screaming their heads
off for any beaten who wasn't Ringo well
my was Elvis in 1956 something about the
way he wiggled his hips just seemed to
send teenage uterus as wild and that
meant sending the parents of those
teenagers into meltdown at a concert in
Jacksonville Florida a judge issued a
pre-emptive arrest warrant against Elvis
for impairing the morals of minors
should he swivel his hips in the state
in his hometown of Tupelo a hundred
National Guardsmen surrounded the stage
to stop a riot from breaking out this
wasn't music it was something dangerous
the aural equivalents of James Dean in
rebel without a cause but Elvis had the
good luck to ride this cultural wave
just as the mainstream caught on at the
beginning of 1956 an outraged Ed
Sullivan declared that had never have
Elvis on his show by September Elvis was
playing the Ed Sullivan Show before an
estimated 60 million people 80% of the
viewing audience 1956 Elvis may have
started out dangerous and sexy but the
mainstream was already embracing him
making him rich but also leaving him
about as edgy as Dennis the Menace by
January 1957 Ed Sullivan was even
telling his viewers that Elvis is a
decent fine boy but the real nail in the
rebel coffin arrived in December that
was the month Elvis was drafted the King
may have played the rebel on stage but
when it came down to it he was a polite
southern patriot and he accepted his
commission without complaint for teens
in the grip of Elvis mania this was the
cultural equivalent of Armageddon tens
of thousands of latter's flooded the
draft board begging for Elvis to be
exempted but the King wanted to go on
March the 24th 1958 Elvis reported for
duty his hair and sideburns were shorn
off in front of the cameras and he was
packed off the basic training before he
went sconul Parker made the boy record a
ton of singles to be slowly released
over the next two years to stop his star
from fading but while Parker would
succeed in keeping Elvis in the public's
mind he
be able to maintain the sexy aura Elvis
had projected just a couple of years
before that was now gone forever over in
Germany Elvis began the newest and
perhaps ickiest chapter of his life in
September 1959 the 24 year old star met
Priscilla Beaulieu who you'll know
better is the future Priscilla Presley
the problem in 1959 she was only 14 and
so we come to the most difficult part of
today's video it is true that this was a
different time Jerry Lee Lewis Chuck
Berry Charlie Chaplin and over the next
decade and a half Jimmy Page David Bowie
and Iggy Pop would all have similar
underage relationships on the other
hands a man in his 20s having a
relationship with the girl of 14 was as
immoral then as it is now and Elvis
seemed to know this although he and
Priscilla did many things together they
always stopped short of sex presumably
so Elvis could avoid a statutory rape
charge the worst of Elvis's behavior is
usually attributed to his later life
drug addiction but his seduction of an
underage girl suggests that there were
problems that stemmed from someplace
much darker the King stints in the army
it finally ended on March 2nd 1960 that
day he was put on a military transport
and flown back to the States just weeks
later he cut the Elvis's back album
after two long years in the wilderness
the King had finally returned
[Music]
the 60s were a weird time to be all this
on the one hand this was the decade when
he became so stinking rich that he never
had to worry about money again on the
other hand it was also the decade when
things started going well a bit weird
let's tackle the successes first between
1960 and 1968
Elvis released some 30 movies nearly all
of them bringing him the studio and
Colonel Tom Parker a tight profit he
also kept recording heads although these
were rarely hits in the era defining way
that that's all right and bin still
Elvis and his family comfortably entered
the 1% allowing him to finally marry the
no longer underage Priscilla in Las
Vegas in 1967 less than a year later
their daughter Lisa Marie Presley was
born all right so that's the highlights
now let's dig into the less good stuff
although Elvis was doing well
financially the movies and songs
bringing that money in were well not so
great artistically watching 60s Elvis is
like watching Michelangelo follow up the
Sistine Chapel by dedicating his life to
paintings of dogs playing poker
you could admire the craft but really
the slump in Elvis's taste can be easily
seen in his legendary 1965 meeting with
the Beatles
although he and the Fab Four eventually
had a good time jamming together John
Lennon's opening remark to the king was
why do you do all these soft centered
ballads for the cinema these days what
happens to good old rock and roll it's
not the only nail that Lennon hits
squarely on the head that day after
their jam session Lennon told people
that Elvis had been stoned the entire
time although the King's hefty drug use
is usually said to have started later it
seems that by the mid 60s he was already
on that slippery slope it was also
during the 1960s that Elvis began to
develop his eating disorder the first
references come from the start of the
decade with interviewers remarking how
Elvis likes to eat pulse of junk food
before the 60s were out the king was
turning to comfort eating more and more
we've read people say that when he was
feeling low eating was the only thing
that could make Elvis film normal again
even his new marriage at a dark side
whatever weird reason Elvis was obsessed
with virginity Priscilla later told an
interviewer that Elvis had mentioned to
me before we were married that he had
never been able to make loved
woman who had a child and that hang up
it remains after Lisa Marie Presley was
born Elvis never had sex with Priscilla
again within a few years the lack of
contact would drive Priscilla to have an
affair that would end their marriage yet
despite all of this the decade ended on
something of a high in early 1968 Tom
Parker had cut a deal with NBC to do a
Bland's one-hour special of Elvis
singing Christmas songs when the project
got underway it slipped out of the
Colonel's control and instead became a
music industry legend sick of being a
bland mass entertainer
Elvis concocted something that would
become known as the 68th comeback
special clad in black leather his figure
once again trim Elvis strode onto the
stage for the last time exuding cool in
a wide-ranging society rocked the
classics did some unplugged acoustic
stuff and engaged in banter with the
audience by the time the curtain went
down over 42 percent of the nation had
tuned in to watch and the feeling was
undeniable 1956 Elvis sexy dangerous
Elvis was back but it was a fleeting
moment a last gasp of rock and roll from
a bygone performer a few months later
Elvis began his residency at the Las
Vegas International Hotel getting paid a
million dollars annually it entertained
tourists over their lobster dinner and
so in the big fight in Elvis's head
between commercial success and artistic
expression it was commercial success
which one
[Music]
the last eight years of Elvis's life or
like watching a slow-motion clown car
crash disturbing but also kind of darkly
amusing by Christmas 1970 Elvis was so
rich and so weird that he was able to
spend a hundred thousand dollars on 32
handguns and ten Mercedes as a present
to himself when Priscilla hit the roof
he stormed out of the house got on a jet
to Washington and decided that he wanted
to meet the president and that's how
well this presently came to be
photographed shaking hands with Richard
Nixon who was so grateful that he gave
the King a badge from the Federal Bureau
of Narcotics and dangerous drugs by now
though once polite southern boy was so
rich he could do whatever he wanted and
he was just surrounded by toadying
yes-men and diving deeper into a drug
habit and what he wanted to do next was
just keep on digging deeper in February
1972 elvis and Priscilla separated with
their divorce coming through a year
later with his wife and child gone Elvis
seems to have lost the last rope
tethering him to Planet Earth oh sure he
still packed out the International in
Las Vegas he still found time to record
late hits like suspicious minds but his
life was now simply one long delayed
suicide attempt by 1975 Elvis was living
as an almost total recluse in Graceland
only waking up long after the Sun had
set like some sort of junk food addicted
vampire speaking of junk food what had
begun as comfort eating had now become
an ugly obsession Elvis's favorite late
life snack was Fool's Gold loaf which
involves taking an entire loaf of bread
hollowing it out and cramming it full of
peanut butter jelly and half a kilo of
bacon before deep-frying the whole thing
the average male consumes around 2,500
calories a day a single Fool's Gold loaf
contains over eight thousand and Elvis
never stops with just a single life in
his last few months Alva started living
with 21-year old ginger Halden who
witnessed his behavior degenerate into
pure self-destruction he would do stuff
like fire his handguns at the TV he once
put a bullet in the wall next to her
head when she tried to make him stop
eating yogurt
I remember earlier when we asked you to
try and imagine what it would have been
like to be Elvis in the summer of 1954
well let's try again now try to imagine
what it must have felt like to be
trapped
in the sagging body locked away in
Graceland never seeing daylight your
soul nothing but an empty void you keep
trying to fill with food and pills now
compare those two mental images and ask
yourself what the hell happened
finally all the abuse it got too much
for Elvis's body on August the 16th 1977
the King died in the bathroom of his
Grayson mansion allegedly while sat on
his throne he was only 42 years old when
the news broke that the king was gone
mourners gathered in vast crowds at
Graceland although the man who died it
had been a bloated drug-addicted mess
that wasn't the man they were there to
remember they were there to remember the
boy who in a few short years in the
1950s had changed their lives opens them
up to a new and dangerous thing called
rock-and-roll as Bruce Springsteen later
said of Elvis's early years it was like
he whispered his dream in all our ears
and then we dreamed it today the jury is
still out and Alice Presley for every
person whose teenage years were lit up
by his voice there is someone else who
only ever saw him as the sweaty fat guy
in Vegas the bygone buffoon who died
while taking a crap yet there's no doubt
that Elvis was an important figure here
was a man who almost single-handedly
forged an entire era in pop culture take
away Elvis and you have no Beatles no
Rolling Stones no foundation for modern
music he may have done some dubious
things he may have ended his life as a
parody of his former self but there's no
doubt that Elvis deserves to be
remembered not as a joke but as a young
man in the summer of 1954 window rolled
down as he drives to his next gig ready
to change the world so I really hope you
found that video interesting if you did
please do hit that thumbs up button
below do not forget to subscribe also
please do check out our fantastic
sponsor Squarespace whoo I'm linking to
you below and thank you for watching
[Music]